[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a sci-fi drama film
called welcome to earth
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the premise of the movie is set in the
year 2618 when the human species has
gone extinct and the earth is not what
it used to be the climate conditions are
so extreme that a powerful sandstorm
covers every part of the earth
throughout the year a spaceship lands on
the surface amidst the sandstorm four
extraterrestrial species step out of the
ship and make their way through the
powerful wind they stop in front of an
entrance to a building the alien who is
leading the group opens the door easily
it is almost as if they have been here
before and are revisiting the earth for
a purpose
following that they get on an elevator
that takes them somewhere under the
ground the building seems to be a bunker
that was constructed to hold life after
the conditions on the surface got too
harsh for the humans to survive when the
elevator stops they come across a
hallway the doors open by themselves
inviting them in on walking inside they
hear a loud noise from behind them and
are startled this notifies the automated
computer system that the aliens can in
fact hear it announces that the sense of
hearing has been detected following that
a bright light flashes onto their faces
forcing them to turn away the automated
voice again claims that visual senses
have been detected it is still unclear
to the aliens what they are dealing with
the voice then asks them if they
encountered a satellite that showed them
the way if yes one of them must be
accustomed to earthly visual concepts
following the announcement three of the
tall aliens take their masks off
revealing their blue complexion and eyes
that only have pupils the leader on the
other hand still stays behind the mask
to test the magnitude of their knowledge
of earthly concepts the automated voice
asks them to select one of the pictures
displayed on the monitor in accordance
with the given word the leader steps
forward to take on the task the first
word he is given is horse among four
pictures of random animals he chooses
sarah jessica parker i mean a horse
next he is asked to choose a tree among
the pictures of a flower a plant and a
mushroom he chooses the tree correctly
proving that he is educated on earth's
concepts at last he is asked to select
the picture of a satellite which he does
perfectly after the brief test the voice
confirms the knowledge and understanding
of speech in the species moments later a
video starts to play on the monitor a
scientist in the video explains that the
place they are in is a museum on human
history that had been established in
2117. it was an effort to preserve
knowledge about humans when they had no
hopes left for survival it is meant to
showcase the history of humanity and was
built with the help of the council of
human preservation only the leader seems
to be understanding the clip while the
others wait for the explanation the
scientist then claims that it is a human
tradition to greet one another and so he
welcomes the aliens to earth he follows
this by saying that unfortunately humans
have gone extinct the last alien is
about to take off his mask but the
comment makes him freeze the professor
in the video explains that the museum
contains 10 billion records and 10
million samples of human society when
the alien involuntarily asks how the
humans went extinct the video stops
playing the system recognizes the
command and proceeds to explain how the
extinction of humans began
it says that humans failed to understand
the true origin of the world but despite
the fact they made significant progress
in technology clips of people landing on
the moon building satellites and doing
revolutionary things are shown the
aliens watch in awe finally
understanding what the earth was like
before the climate change however soon
the clips change from happy to
destructive ones countries and states
fight for territories the aliens realize
that humans took too much from nature to
the point that nature couldn't save them
anymore
they were the cause of their own
downfall as a last resort to save the
world the officials decided to ask for
help from extraterrestrial creatures
with whom they share the universe
for this they sent human ambassadors to
different parts of space to look for
aliens and ask for help as the screen
shows the pictures of said ambassadors
the leader touches the face of one of
them named renee shepard the computer
detects the touch input and starts to
explain the story of the ambassador
renee had joined the fleet in 2087 and
was one of the seven ambassadors who
were sent to look for extraterrestrial
creatures he was selected fourth in a
class of 400 people a flashback shows
renee attending a training session the
ambassadors had to take before they were
set for the mission the com officer
whitney explains to them about a black
box called the knowledge probe that is
made especially for the mission the
device contains everything that is
necessary to teach an alien about
earthly language and behavior when the
ambassadors finally meet an alien
species they are supposed to use it to
teach them about the planet and convince
them to aid humans whitney also explains
that they have already sent thousand
such devices to different parts of space
the last seven boxes will be accompanied
by the ambassadors right before they are
sent off for the mission representative
alice tells them that this might be the
most important mission for humankind and
expresses gratitude towards all the
ambassadors who are willing to risk
their lives for their people at the end
of the convention they swear to find
extraterrestrial help or die trying to
do so the ambassadors including renee
are allowed to meet their families for
one last time his father asks him to
send a postcard from space to which he
jokingly says that he will make an alien
bring it his mother on the other hand is
worried for her son's safety she asks
him to pilot the space pod safely he
kisses his wife and takes a picture with
his family hoping that he will meet them
again the ambassador who takes the
picture is his best friend tess the
ambassadors then finally board the space
pods that each of them is supposed to
pilot renee puts his family's picture on
the control panel and gets ready for the
initiation of the mission his wife tells
his parents she has a feeling all of
this is wrong but it is too late for
renee to turn back the pods finally take
off and soon enter hyperdrive renee
experiences some heavy turbulence
because of the speed of the pod but it
soon stops when he reaches his first
destination he starts the scans for the
first waypoint to check if the area is
inhabited by any extraterrestrial beings
back in the control room each ambassador
has their own com officers who report to
them on what they have to do next when
rene's results come back negative he is
told to jump further into space to the
second point he drives through space at
a very high speed again one of renee's
colleagues is already at his fourth
waypoint when he doesn't find the
evidence of living beings he tries to
jump to the other part of space but his
pod explodes killing him instantly
now only six ambassadors are left back
in the control room they try to check
his vitals but receive no signal they
realize that he is dead and cover his
part of the control panel with a white
cloth following that whitney announces
to all the officers that they have lost
one of their ambassadors which creates
tension among them they have an
emergency meeting to figure out who is
the most sus
yet they remain professional and carry
on with the mission in the meantime
ambassador tess is in her 18th waypoint
going stronger than everyone else
however one after another the
ambassadors begin to die because of pod
malfunctions oxygen failures and getting
way too close to a star after a few days
tess renee and one other ambassador are
the only ones left tess asks the com
officer how everyone is doing to which
she lies and says that they are fine
tess jokingly says that she will beat
renee to the mission and continues the
jump however she gets too close to the
sun during the jump and dies
she really committed to that joke back
on earth her control panel is also
covered in a white cloth it has been
several days since the mission started
and renee is on waypoint 213.
he asks the com officer about tess to
keep his spirit up the officer lies and
says that tess is doing great he also
playfully comments that he will beat her
to the aliens and continues the jump
after the comment another ambassador
dies leaving renee as the only surviving
one on his way to waypoint 214 renee's
pod starts to malfunction everyone on
earth who is hoping for his survival is
on their feet the com officer tries to
retrieve data from the pod but fails
eventually renee loses all control of
the pod and it crashes on a blue planet
that looks awfully like the earth since
the pod lands on land with a thick layer
of snow on top renee has no fatal
injuries however the temperature of the
planet is way lower than his body can
handle his face turns blue with
frostbite as he looks at the picture of
his family in the end even the last
ambassador is lost leaving humanity with
no hopes for survival the cause of death
is recorded to be rapid freezing due to
a hostile atmosphere if coincidentally
the planet has an intelligent species
living on it renee's preserved body
still has a 10 chance of revival the
representative alice tells whitney that
they cannot announce the deaths to the
public because then the people will go
into a frenzy whitney who is mourning
the soldiers deaths harshly claims that
the men who died for humanity deserve
respect however alice stays put in her
decision although the public was kept in
the dark they informed the families of
the ambassadors of their deaths a
private funeral is held in honor of them
his death marked the end of the alien
outreach program no alien help was found
as they had predicted back in the bunker
the last alien takes off his mask and
reveals that he is actually renee the
only ambassador who completed the
mission successfully and brought alien
aid to the earth but he is too late we
can predict that he was revived by the
blue-skinned aliens who are inhabitants
of the snowy planet the computer
announces that renee's files contain
more than 10 000 messages 800 pictures
and some video entries left by his loved
ones he asks the computer to show all of
them the movie ends as he watches a
video of him hugging his family before
his departure subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching